welcome back to CBS mornings where we
have got a story for you earlier this
month 35 year old Sheldon Thomas walked
out of a Brooklyn New York courtroom
free after almost two decades Behind
Bars Thomas was arrested back in 2004
for murder after an eyewitness pointed
to a picture of a guy named Sheldon
Thomas in a police lineup of photos but
the man in the image was actually a
different person entirely happened to
have the same name and as we stepped
through the circles of absurdity here
that guy also had no link to the case
nevertheless prosecutors continued to
focus on the Sheldon Thomas they had in
custody which eventually led to his
wrongful conviction Thomas talked to our
Lilia Luciano just days after his
release in his very first TV interview
I'm waiting for this my whole life
Sheldon Thomas was 16 when police took
down the door of his home and locked him
up now 19 years later he's been
effectively exonerated what's been hard
about just being out and about it's been
so little time just like what you said
being out and about
uh Justin being around people Thomas was
convicted for second-degree murder in
the December 2004 death of a 14 year old
boy in Brooklyn attorneys William Casten
and Leslie ressinger have worked with
Thomas for more than a decade they say
the case should have never even made it
to trial how much of his case was based
on Lies 100 from the police interaction
to him every party fails him in the
system in a pre-trial hearing a
detective lied then admitted to lying on
the stand and the case still moved
forward he has arrested based on
a photo that is not his the people
involved in decision making refused to
accept the fact that a mistake was made
how can a jury reach a fair verdict
it was rigged from the start the unit
that reviewed his case after years of
failed appeals concluded that Thomas was
denied due process at every stage and
found one of the detectives involved had
been harassing Thomas after a prior
arrest and lied about knowing him did
you ever feel like they were targeting
you specifically most definitely it
should have been the other way around
you're innocent until proven guilty from
my lenses where I see life is always
like that for people like me
for people that look like me it's always
like that
you're guilty until you actually prove
that you're innocent nearly two decades
later he finally stepped into what still
feels like a mirage of freedom I haven't
even cried yet since I've been home like
I haven't even got to the point where it
actually hit me I still have dreams
about being in prison I'm scared to go
to sleep as the days go by
it Dawns on me
a little bit more a little bit more Mr
Thomas motion to vacuum the conviction
is granted at a hearing this month
Thomas shared how his Hope was sustained
for so long by releasing resentment when
I was sentenced tell Judith said that I
deserve to spend the rest of my life a
person he was wrong
I didn't deserve what happened and
I'm forgiving I know I've lost 20 years
already but ultimately I prevailed
I don't like losing so I have to like go
because I don't want that to be what
defines me as a human as a person I want
love to Define me
Sheldon says he can't sleep because he's
afraid that he's going to wake up and it
was all a dream he can't sleep because
of the other inmates he met up at Attica
who he believes are there innocent we
reached out to the detective that we
mentioned in this case who was in the
involved in the original arrest that he
said he did not want to comment
um you know here's one thing that the
attorney told me when you when you
commit a crime and you serve your
sentence when you walk out there is
resources there is assistance
um for him they just open the door and
you're on your own so he gets no
assistance whatsoever nothing right now
he's relying on his elderly mother to
who's working a second shift to support
him and on crowdfunding that his
attorney set up yeah and eventually
perhaps he may Sue and maybe he'll win
but he's not ready for that right now
he's just focusing what's it like for
him to be around people well that's what
he was saying he said we were walking
around Central Park and he said when
you're in prison the only time you get
outside you're in the yard and if
somebody gets close to you normally it's
not a good thing it's not a good thing
you're going to get attacked so he he
feels like that self-preservation means
isolation and even with his family he
says I feel so bad because they reach
out to me and I just need the Solitude
yes I hopefully he will allow himself a
good cry he certainly deserves and needs
that but I Marvel that he can sit here
today after the Injustice that happened
to him and say I forgive them I would
still need help on that I mean and I
want love to Define it yeah he he's
going to need a lot of you know therapy
and and we talked so much I wish I wish
I could share everything but he did I
asked them what got you through it and
he said Victor Frankel's book emances
one of the greatest books I've ever read
it over and over and he read about this
man in a concentration camp and he said
well at least that's not this and if he
can get through it and all those lessons
got him looks incredible he's an amazing
human being yeah incredible Grace
most inspired person I've met in my life
wow I get that saying a lot because
you've met a lot of people yeah Lilia
thank you very much